in a free nation therefore reason is in
truth realized it is a present living
spirit in which the individual not only
finds his essential character that is
his universal and particular nature
expressed and present to him in the form
of thing hood but is himself this
essence and also has realized that
essential character the wisest men of
antiquity have therefore declared that
wisdom and virtue consists in living in
accordance with the customs of one's own
nation
paragraph 352 is building off of this
idea that Hegel has introduced just
earlier of ethical substance here he's
going to talk in terms of a free nation
Frei at folk a you don't necessarily
have to think in terms of a nation state
but rather any sort of ethnic grouping
any sort of community that isn't
necessarily defined in terms of its
genetics although it often will turn out
to be the case for that but rather in
terms of having some sort of system of
norms in place that are at least
acknowledged they're going to be
violated by some of the people but norms
are in fact acknowledged by the
punishment of the violation are the ways
in which people have to compromise in
order to reconcile the the violation of
them but these these norms laws and
customs as he's talked about in in the
previous passages here he's just going
to talk about customs in it but laws are
already being being sort of built into
that this is the way in which reason he
says is realized is is made real is made
effective as he says in truth invar
height now that's very important because
we have this motion or movement that's
occurring continuously in the
phenomenology going from certainty
something that's that's being grasped
something that's immediate to trying to
grasp the truth of it and in the process
of trying to assure ourselves of the
truth rather than just merely the
certainty we often end up losing the
certainty going through this process of
alienation you know and then we have to
recuperate it or reconcile it or you
know have some sort of in a way of
bringing things back together and
integrating them however you want to
conceive of it so Hegel starting off
here in 352 talking about the big
ending of a process which at first seems
quite harmonious like everything has
come together and we have a nice you
know seemingly static state where
everything has been reconciled
everything's worked out it's not going
to remain like that very long so what
we're doing here is setting out the the
launching pad you might say and he talks
about the individual and the nation as
being connected together in he says a
present living spirit the individual not
only finds his essential character that
is as Hegel says his universal and his
particular nature expressed and present
him in the form of thing hood in the
form of a thing in the form of something
objective something that he can see
something that he can understand about
himself he finds that in the nation in
this this gathering in this grouping
that the person belongs to that they
probably you know didn't have any choice
about joining originally and he goes on
and he says it is is himself this
essence the essence and he has realized
the essential character the the nation
is providing the essence for the
individual and so Hegel then talks about
the wisest sages of antiquity counseling
that the laws and customs of one's
nation to follow those is indeed the
height of wisdom of ice height and
virtue to get you know these two sort of
Co relative terms of understanding and
behaving correctly doing things
correctly being the right way and Hegel
is not actually endorsing this as a kind
of cultural relativism or an unthinking
acceptance of the norms the laws the
customs of one's one's own you know
nation or location or anything like that
but he is saying that
this is something that is an important
step along the way
but from this happy state of having
realized it's essential character and of
living in it self-consciousness which at
first is spirit only immediately and in
principle has withdrawn or else has not
yet realized it for both may equally
well be set
in paragraph 353 we have the beginning
of a process of alienation of the
individual self-consciousness from the
society from the the group from the folk
that we've been talking about so far it
can be translated also as nation if we
like and Hegel begins by talking about
this happy state that we just saw
you know mentioned in the previous
paragraph this is what we're gonna be
trying to get back to for a long time
as we go through the phenomenology and
sometimes thinking that we've got it but
then finding out no it it slips between
our fingers and this is a case in which
there is kind of a you might say
coincidence but not not simply an
identity but a dynamic relationship
between the individual self conscious
individual the reasoner and the ethical
substance of the society this is this is
the unity of spirit and Hegel says that
what's going on in this happy state is
that the individual has realized their
essential character and even more than
that they are living in that essential
character and this is this is something
he's gonna talk and later passages here
he mentions happiness but happiness
itself is going to become an object that
is going to be pursued because of this
you might say sort of nostalgia for this
this happy state and we have an
alienation here why because as Hegel
points out the individual the the
self-consciousness isn't really spirit
in a full way nor in their seeming unity
with their society and its ways of
understanding the rest of the world
including itself it's only implicitly
and in principle or not the Griffith
after the concept spirit it's not yet
spirit so what is separating it from
spirit
the fact that self-consciousness itself
has as he says withdrawn or yeah you
know it literally is withdraw and
although that's you know the way of
using this kind of verb in the past
tense Houska Totten it's it's walked out
right or it isn't it has not yet
realized this this essential character
Nick Nolte Ohio is not yet brought to
fulfillment that character in itself and
so here we are seeing the beginning of a
long process of moving away from the
ethical substance which is always going
to involve a desire to be reunited with
it
reason must withdraw from this happy
state for the life of a free people is
only in principle or immediately the
reality of an ethical order in other
words the ethical order exists merely is
something given therefore this Universal
spirit itself is a separate individual
spirit and the customs and laws and
their entirety are a specific ethical
substance which only in the higher stage
that is in spirits consciousness of its
essence sheds this limitation and in
this knowledge alone has its absolute
truth not directly as it immediately is
in the latter form it is a limited
ethical substance and absolute
limitation as just this that spirit is
in the form of mere being
it's very important here in paragraph
354 to be able to see what Hegel's
criticism if you like of the ethical
substances it nikka substance truly is
and not to mix it up with something else
like say a complaint about relativism or
something along those lines although
that that is going to play you might say
a limited part in in practice in where
he's going with this
so what we're interested in is the
domain of universal spirit right and we
thought that we found this in the life
of the free people and by participating
in that life perhaps through you know
fulfilling one's social roles or by you
know working for one's own good and
thereby working for the good of the
other by following the norms or even you
know reinterpreting the norms all that
sort of stuff one was able to have this
relationship of a harmonious coexistence
as part of the the greater whole the
individual and the what it exceeds the
individual what transcends individual
were thereby integrated but we saw that
that that that starts to fall apart and
and why is that the case well when we
think about what he's calling the life
of the free people the the folk right he
calls this as what Miller's translating
here something given something that is
you might say just taken for for granted
the word that he uses here is not given
like you know gig a band or anything
like that its Zion de but we've seen
that when something is a sign or just
you know advice or eyeness Zion does
something that that happens to be it
seems as if it it lacks a certain
necessity it seems rather arbitrary and
so if you think about norms
and the way that they work laws and
customs and I said well why do we do
things this way oh well that's just the
way we happen to do it or there may be
some sort of determination that that
takes place at some point but after a
while it comes to seem like well it
could have happened differently we just
are following along with this you know
we're reacting say to environmental
conditions or some guy like this
particular aesthetic and we just stuck
with it all sorts of examples so
something given and Hegel talks about
this and here's where we're getting to
the real meat of it he talks about this
as being a what Milligan Miller's
translating and rightly so as specific
ethical substance now the German for
this is a shrimp the zaleka substance no
problem with the zaleka than ethical
right
basim de another way of translating this
is determined or determinate so insofar
as it has been determined in a
particular way say let's take for
example eating certain foods and not
eating other foods and there's there may
be all sorts of reasons why you know one
shouldn't eat this kind of food in this
sort of environment and you know all
sorts of things along those lines or
there might be reasons that have to do
with the aesthetics of taste or anything
like that but insofar as it is best Impa
insofar as it's determined insofar as
it's specific it is leaving some things
out
it's excluding them it's in a certain
way not quite Universal but this is the
answer tragedy in order to try to be
universally you've got to determine some
things and yet if you determine them
then you wind up being limited and the
word that's translated here is limited
it's really quite interesting
mashenka right Hegel could have said he
could have talked in terms of borders or
Glen's oh right that would have maybe a
more neutral term but the shrank
has this connotation at least to my ears
of being kind of closed in on itself
not yet claustrophobic but certainly we
say a little parochial a little you know
closed off and what Hegel's saying is
this is what the life of the free people
really is like why is that a problem he
says this universal spirit itself is a
separate individual spirit and the
customs and laws in their entirety are
specific ethical substance which only in
the higher stage in spirits
consciousness of its essence sheds this
limitation and in this knowledge alone
has its absolute truth that's what it's
driving after in the life of a specific
great living wonderful people there's a
kind of restricted miss to it and it's
not embodying this higher stage the
absolute truth which is the possibility
for it there's something thereby lacking
to it even though it seems to be a
plenitude it's lacking so he goes on and
he says what becomes what we realize is
it's a limited ethical substance and
absolute limitation is just this that
spirit is in the form of a mere being
again we have the finest scientists
right spirit has been reduced to
something that merely is I'm a Frenchman
I am a ancient Greek from Athens
I am a Hegel scholar and part about you
know community perhaps right although a
rather attenuated one what is the issue
here notice what he's not saying Hegel
is not saying well you know this is
limited and we could have thought about
it a whole bunch of other different ways
and there's a whole bunch of other
communities and they see things
different ways so this can't be the
ethical substance because you know why
why do they get to claim to be that when
when the other ones could have just as
good of a claim he's not saying that at
this point what he is saying is
something about the nature of
determination in general when it comes
to ethical substance and he's also got
the individual in the background of this
universal spirit
further therefore the single individual
consciousness as it exists immediately
in the real ethical order or in the
nation is a solid unshaken Trust in
which Spirit has not for the individual
resolved itself into its abstract
moments and therefore he is not aware of
himself as being a pure individuality on
his own account but once he has arrived
at this idea as he must then this
immediate unity with spirit
the mere being of himself in spirit his
trust is lost
isolated and on his own it is he who is
now the essence no longer in the
universal spirit this individuality of
self-consciousness is it is true a
moment in universal spirit itself but
only as a vanishing quantity which
appearing on its own it is at once
resolved within Universal spirit and
enters consciousness merely as trust in
thus establishing himself and each
moment because it is a moment to the
essence must succeed in exhibiting
itself as the essence the individual has
thereby placed himself in opposition to
the laws and customs these are regarded
as mere ideas having no absolute
essential 'ti an abstract theory without
any reality while he as this particular
eye is his own living truth
what may have seemed quite abstract in
the previous paragraphs now in paragraph
355 becomes very concrete very easy to
visualize because there's a stark
opposition that we're gonna be looking
at one between the individual and the
society along with its norms its customs
its laws this is a very important
transition point for our movement into
the sections that follow the real meat
of this particular portion of the
reasons section so Hegel says the single
individual consciousness as it exists
immediately in the real ethical order or
the nation right the full when that is
going on when it's still in that happy
state everything is nice everything is
wonderful there's this interplay between
the two but what we don't have there is
a pure individuality an EIN zone height
right there's no insulin there's no
individuality the individual is you
might say sort of submerged it's not as
if they don't have agency or the
capacity to say I at all or to take
responsibility but they're doing so in a
restricted way we talk about people not
really knowing who they are figured out
who they are
and needing to go find themselves this
is part of what Hegel is discussing here
so he says it exists in a solid unshaken
trust in which spirit is not for the
individual resolved itself into its
abstract moments therefore he's not
aware of himself as being a pure
individuality on his own account doesn't
mean again like I said that he does he's
not aware of himself as an individuality
but he's not aware just what
individuality means which is the
capacity to you might say take
responsibility
for oneself to stand against the norms
which is what's going to happen next so
he goes on and he says once he has
arrived
at this idea as he must now notice that
he term as he must what is Hagel saying
here this is something that we see
happen in the life of so many people
they they begin and sometimes it happens
in adolescence or you know early
adulthood sometimes it only happens much
much later somebody has been a company
person and they worked for the benefit
of the company this whole time thinking
that the company was going to reward
them and take account of what a great
guy or great gal they are and suddenly
they realize no if that's not the way it
actually is I'm being taken advantage of
I've got to look out for myself what
about my retirement what about the
meaning of my own existence I should
start sending my resume these things
happen in very concrete ways it's not
always somebody you know being involved
in a Greek tragedy we know that that
this has to happen in it can happen in a
multitude of ways but Hegel goes on and
he says this immediate unity with the
Spirit the mere being of himself in
spirit his trust this talent is the word
that he uses several times in this
passage this trust is now lost what does
that mean notice how Hegel then sketches
things out isolated on his own and
German is actually useful here right it
is he who is now the essence the
individual now becomes the essential or
if we want to be very literal about this
as Miller is here the individual becomes
the essence the daisen the being that
has importance the being that is not
just a being but the being around which
the other beings sent
to the being that other beings
constellated
what about universal spirit
well universal spirit understood as the
community and understood as its norms is
no longer the essential this is a
radical change this is a shock when you
come to realize that what you have been
taken as sort of the moral world around
you no longer operates the way that you
think it does when the veil is pulled
back when the masks are torn off there's
a moment of shock or perhaps sometimes
even a lifetime of shock for some people
sometimes people never snap out of it
and you realize oh I could do anything
and it might be okay because I'm
bringing myself around with me I don't
have to actually bring those laws and
norms around with me I can decide
whether I'm going to accept them or not
this is actually sort of an
existentialist moment here in Hegel
right so if you ever read you know
Kierkegaard and critique or Sartre and
critique well there's there's some Hegel
that's like that so he goes on he says
this individuality of self-consciousness
is it is true a moment in universal
spirit itself but only as a vanishing
quantity which appearing on its own is
at once resolved within universal spirit
and enters consciousness merely as trust
so Universal spirit is being sort of
rejected it's not that Universal spirit
in a broader sense isn't there what the
relationship that the individual is able
to have with it is only one of trust and
that trust must become something
different than the the trust that was
over here there is no trust anymore over
here right that's been lost what does
the individual have what does the
individual want he says in establishing
itself and each moment because it is a
moment of the
essence must succeed in exhibiting
itself as the essence the individual has
placed himself in opposition to the laws
and the customs to the universal spirit
that was what was going on here in the
ethical order the individual says I may
not follow the laws I have to decide
whether the laws and customs actually
worked for me and I'm the essential one
because I'm the one who actually gets to
make that determination for myself now
this places them in a somewhat
compromising and compromised position
but it's one that's that's going to be
quite important for the development of
the individual
he says they realized that the laws and
customs are mere ideas having no
absolute essential 'ti in the past they
could look at those laws and customs as
well that's just what everyone does of
course I'm going to do that because I'm
I'm that kind of person I belong
afterwards after this awareness this you
know becoming awakened or having one's
eyes opened so wait a second those those
don't compel me some people follow them
other people don't I have to decide
which one I'm going to be and the mere
fact that some people think I ought to
behave that way or mom and dad said that
or some you know book or some elders go
around preaching about that doesn't mean
that I have to do it this is a very
important moment so he says there
they're you know regarded as mere ideas
an abstract theory without any reality
but the individual as the particular eye
is as Hegel says his own living truth so
instead of mere trust the individual
feels him or herself to be the truth
and they are now going to try to work
that out it's one thing to feel it is
another that's another thing to think it
it's another thing to think it through